schönen guten Abend das ist ja der
corona-gipfel bei Bild live mit der
wichtigsten Frage geht Deutschland
wieder doch wieder in den Lockdown die
richtigen Fragen heute an Helge braun
den Kanzleramtschef von Angela Merkel
der corona-gipfel Drahtzieher sozusagen
im Kanzleramt und der Mann der jetzt
selber cdu-parteichef werden möchte
Wolfgang Kubicki Deutschlands größte
vielleicht letzte Hoffnung im Kampf
gegen einen neuen Lockdown und
zugeschaltet Karl Lauterbach der SPD
corona-papst zugeschaltet aus der
Karnevalshochburg aus Köln und
zugeschaltet aus München Markus Blume
Söders general im Team Vorsicht ihnen
allen schönen guten Abend und erste
Frage direkt in diese Runde vielleicht
Antwort per Handzeichen wer garantiert
uns dennoch allen deutschen das kein
neuer Lockdown kommt
gibt es jemanden unter ihnen Vieren
nein niemand auch nicht Herr Kubicki ich
bin der Überzeugung dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
flächendeckenden lockdowns in ganz
Deutschland gegen Null geht aber
Garantien abgeben das haben mich die
letzten zwei Jahre gelernt gelehrt kann
keiner ich wundere mich ein bisschen
weil ihr Parteichef Christian Lindner ja
das gesagt hat vor kurzem er hat gesagt
das wird eben nicht das Mittel der Ampel
sein er hat genau das mit diesem
Lockdown versprechen ausgeschlossen
einen neuen Lockdown Herr kubiki das
heißt schon umgefallen wenn ich sage die
Wahrscheinlichkeit gegen Null geht gegen
Null dann ist das ja identisch Lockdown
hat auch Markus Söder ausgeschlossen
Ende August ein Lockdown hat Volker
Bouffier ausgeschlossen noch vor einigen
Wochen Lockdown hat ja eigentlich auch
die Kanzlerin ausgeschlossen als
flächendeckend wenn wir ehrlich sind den
wird es auch so nicht geben aber was wir
nicht ausschließen können ist das Lokal
wenn sie Städte haben mit Inzidenzen
über 1000 Lokal die Behörden vor Ort
auch erklären können
Läden geschlossen werden müssen Schulen
geschlossen werden die Frage ist nur wie
viel lokale lockdowns diese Garantie von
Herrn Lindner dann einschließt weil wenn
wir flächendeckend am Ende lokale oder
regionale lockdowns haben haben wir ja
auch ein Bundes Lockdown nein wir werden
das Infektionsschutzgesetz gerade
novellieren und da wird genau festgelegt
nach welchen Kriterien was geschehen
kann und wie gesagt der Gesetzentwurf
ist eingebracht worden letzten
Donnerstag morgen wird der in der
Anhörung beraten das ist ein normales
gesetzgeberisches Verfahren was ja braun
schon gar nicht mehr kennt und nach der
Anhörung wird dann entschieden wie die
endgültige Fassung aussieht nächsten
Donnerstag verabschiedet werden wird
Herr Lauterbach sind sie am Ende
derjenige der Lindners Garantie Lindners
versprechen kassiert und der auch ein
Kubicki dazu bringt dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit eben doch nicht gegen
Null geht sondern gegen 100%
hat ja recht dass es also lokale
lockdowns durchaus geben könntet und man
muss auch mitdenken also
selbstverständlich kann eine ganz andere
Variante noch kommen also wenn wir eine
Variante zum Beispiel plötzlich hätten
die deutlich ansteckender ist als die
Delta Variante oder schlimmer noch eine
Variante die das gelingt die Impfungen
zu überwinden das haben wir ja bei der
Delta Variante für die Stadtgarten
Impfungen in Teilen auch schon aber da
wäre es denkbar dass da eine andere
Variante kommt die sehr viel stärker
über die Impfungen weggeht die wir
derzeit verabreichen und verabreicht
haben dann wären natürlich andere
Maßnahmen notwendig von daher hat Herr
Kubicki recht das ist medizinisch
zumindest ich kann hier nur als
Mediziner als also Epidemiologen als
Arzt sprechen würde es medizinisch
natürlich keinen Sinn machen ein solches
kategorisches Versprechen abzugeben Herr
Blume das klingt jetzt schon wieder zum
Einstieg in der Sendung so als gäbe es
lockdowns also regionale lockdowns
ohnehin und möglicherweise dann überall
in Deutschland regionale lockdowns
ich bin etwas verwundert gerade über die
letzten Beiträge weil sie völlig zu
Recht darauf hingewiesen haben dass von
den Partei Spitzen da zum Teil ganz
andere Töne in den letzten Tagen
gesendet wurden fakt ist ich bin in
tiefer Sorge weil natürlich die
corona-entwicklung in vielen Teilen
Deutschlands insbesondere im Süden und
Osten dramatisch ist und ich bin zum
zweiten in Sorge weil die Politik mit
den neuen Mehrheiten im Deutschen
Bundestag offensichtlich nicht gewillt
ist den bisherigen Kurs bei Corona
vorzusetzen also da wird das Team
vorsichtig jetzt abgelöst quasi von dem
Thema Team fahrlässig ich halte das für
einen schweren Fehler dass man sich
voreilig festgelegt hat dass man die
epidemische Notlage nicht verlängern
will und damit ein ganz wichtigen
Instrumentenkasten aus der Hand gibt und
jetzt hektisch versucht noch irgendwie
nachzustrecken das ist nicht das was
gerade die Länder jetzt brauchen
deswegen ist gut und wichtig dass noch
in dieser Woche der bund-ländergipfel
stattfindet wenn wir ehrlich sind
eigentlich schon wieder zu spät das
diskutieren wir gleich noch mal tiefer
vor allen Dingen die epidemische Notlage
Herr aber um das noch mal festzustellen
wenn die Ampel sich da offenbar bewegt
gerade und ein bisschen Richtung
bayerische Linie wieder tendiert das
dröseln wir gleich auf Herr Kubicki dann
ist die Union ist in Bayern die CSU und
sie sind mit der CDU die letzte
verlässliche Lockdown Partei für
Deutschland nein es geht jetzt überhaupt
nicht um die Kategorie Lockdown ja oder
nein sondern es geht darum die Zahlen
steigen massiv und deshalb brauchen wir
ein Infektionsschutzgesetz dass die
Länder handlungsfähig hält und wenn die
Ampelkoalition jetzt ein Gesetz
verabschiedet wo lauter Möglichkeiten
zum Beispiel kontaktbeschränkungen gar
nicht mehr vorgesehen sind dann kann man
eben wie alle gesagt haben wir können
nicht sicher in die Zukunft gucken dann
haben wir aber ein Gesetz was keine
Vorsorge trifft für solche schwierigen
Situationen reicht dieses Gesetz was
jetzt durch den Bundestag geht am
Donnerstag dann im Bundestag beschlossen
werden soll am Freitag im Bundesrat
nicht weit genug mit derzeitigen Zustand
sind zum Beispiel kontaktbeschränkungen
nicht gesehen das ist zu wenig Herr
Blume ihnen geht das auch nicht weit
genug
ich sehe das genauso das ist der
entscheidende Punkt wichtige Elemente in
diesem Gesetz fehlen wir bräuchten eine
klare Regelung für das Thema Zweige plus
Herr Kubicki ist ja eher auf eine ganz
anderen Spur der hat in den letzten
Tagen vor Aufsehen gesorgt mit dem Thema
1g ich glaube das ist eine Grund falsche
Weichenstellung wir brauchen mehr an
Schutz und zwei g Plus ist ein wichtiger
ein wichtiges Konzept und ja in der Tat
es fehlen noch weitergehende
Regelungsmöglichkeiten für das Thema
kontaktbeschränkung kontaktbeschränkung
kontaktbeschränkungen für ungeimpfte
dass kann und wird möglicherweise ein
weiterer Baustein sein den wir zumindest
brauchen im Instrumentenkoffer und dass
die neue ampelregierung da nicht willens
ist alle möglichen Instrumente in die
Hand zu nehmen halte ich für einen
schweren Fehler Herr kopiegel lassen sie
dann noch mal mit sich reden an der
Stelle also dieses Gesetz auszuweiten
zunächst einmal scheint es dass der
Blume gar nicht verstanden hat worum es
geht weil 1g bedeutet niemand kommt in
der Altenpflegeheime hinein ob genesen
die Teams oder getestet
die genesen gegeben oder umgeimpft der
nicht getestet worden ist keiner betritt
mehr in alten- und Pflegeheim oder eine
oder ein Krankenhaus der nicht getestet
worden ist weil wir wissen mittlerweile
das von von geimpfen auch an
Infektionsgefahr ausgehen kann wir haben
ja auch einige Ausbrüche in
Altenpflegeheimen die eingetragen worden
sind von geimpften also das ist eine
ganz sichere Form ist aber nicht
verstanden sie damit besänftigt oder
fehlt ihnen noch etwas ganz entscheidend
von halben Schutz ich rede von doppelten
Schutz geimpft und getestet beides
zusammen ist nach menschlicher messen
das sicherste was wir Moment haben nur
getestet ist deutlich zu wenig weil wir
wissen dass es natürlich auch viel
falsch negative gibt ich bin immer
begeistert dass ich sehr Ratschläge
bekomme von Menschen die zu Hause
dokumentieren dass sie die Lage nicht im
Griff haben
zunächst selbst darauf hingewiesen er
braucht Konkretisierung bei 2G bei 2g+
die momentan im Gesetz gar nicht
vorhanden sind wir konkretenisieren das
jetzt wir haben festgestellt dass die
impfstation wechseln wollen sind ein
großer Fehler wir brauchen sehr schnell
wieder sehr viele impfstationen weil wir
ansonsten die 20 Millionen Menschen die
gebootet werden müssen bis Weihnachten
das machen wir jetzt die
kontaktbeschränkung das sind der ist der
Punkt dass der Punkt von Herrn Braun das
ist momentan unser Problem nicht die
kontaktbeschränkung sondern die
Wiederherstellung der Handlungsfähigkeit
nicht nur der politischen Entscheidung
lassen Sie nicht mit sich reden das
kommt nicht rein das wird nicht oben
drauf gepackt auf das möglicherweise
nicht ausreichende Gesetz was sie da
gerade durch die Bundestag wenn wir wenn
wir kontaktbeschränkungen brauchen dann
muss das durch parlamentarische Beratung
geschehen was wir nicht mehr wollen da
sind wir uns alle einig oh das ist das
Ministerpräsidenten das verschlossenen
Türen machen spricht doch gar nichts die
Frage trotzdem ganz klar diese bisher
nicht beantworten wollten
kontaktbeschränkungen lassen sie dann
noch mal mit sich reden kommt das
nachträglich noch rein in das Gesetz wir
haben ja schon kontaktbeschränkungen
wenn sie in öffentliche Veranstaltung
nicht mehr gehen können außer zwei g
haben sie eine kontaktbeschränkung für
ungeimpft ist aber nicht die Definition
des Gesetzes wir haben jetzt mit der
epidemischen Lage die Möglichkeit zu
sagen nur Gruppen in gewisser Größe
können sich wir brauchen noch einmal
normalerweise würde ich würde ich von
der Union jetzt erwarten dass sie auf
der Grundlage des Entwurfes des
Infektionsschutzes ihre eigenen
Vorschläge einbringt und nicht einfach
nur über die Fernsehkameras organisiert
warum bringt die cdu/c zu
Bundestagsfraktion nicht eine
ergänzungsvorschlagen über die wir dann
beraten können wir haben ehrlich gesagt
momentan die Situation dass wir einfach
die epidemische Lage verlängern können
und wir könnten noch eine Sache machen
da bin ich mit ihnen vielleicht wir
streichen die ausgangsbeschränkung die
Ausgangssperren raus weil da bin ich
ganz sicher dass wir es wirklich nicht
mehr machen und ansonsten verlängern wir
die epidemische Lage eins zu eins dann
ist die Sache schon gelernt es geht gar
nicht ohne weiteres weil wir ihre
dreijährigen für die für die Betriebe
einführen müssen also wir müssen das
Gesetz schon ein bisschen ändern und und
ansprechen wir haben momentan keine
klare Regelungen für zwei g2g+ oder für
3G das machen wir denn da momentan auf
rechts unsichere Grundlage wir haben
doch mit allen gesprochen also entweder
sie wollen eine sichere Grundlage für
Maßnahmen oder Sie wollen